welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and HBO is The Last of Us season
one has come to an end and now new
reports have confirmed that part two of
the game will span multiple Seasons if
you watch this season carefully little
Easter eggs and cameos were snuck in
setting up major parts of season two
that will surely Circle back on and say
oh they did the thing I'm gonna break
down these overlooked details and
everything Neil druckman and Craig Mason
have teased about season two I'm going
to touch on some stuff that comes up in
part two of the games but I will precede
any big reveals with another spoiler
warning so if you're terrified to know
anything about part two of the game well
why the [__] did you click on this video
but since you're here thank you I will
take care of you and I will give you
just enough to get excited for the road
ahead while properly marking any
upcoming spoilers sinkholes hey
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive I got a deep dive on the original
John Whitby You're Gonna Love coming on
Friday and if you're going to WonderCon
this year I'll be doing a panel with
other new rockstars hosts on Friday
March 24th at 2 30 room 213 a b come
hang out with us and thank you to
Harry's for sponsoring this video more
on them in a moment okay druckman and
Mason confirmed in an interview with GQ
that part two of the game would would be
adapted over multiple Seasons at least
two but he wouldn't confirm if it was
more than that in January the series was
renewed by HBO for a second season so
this is an update that there will be at
least three seasons of The Last of Us on
HBO so without going too far into the
plot of part 2 an important character to
part two of the game is Abby the actress
who plays Abby in the game Laura Bailey
cameos in the season finale playing one
of the nurses who AIDS the Firefly
doctor Dr Anderson and the surgery prep
for the attraction of the cordyceps from
Ellie's brain she's the nurse with the
darker sleeves behind the bed closer to
Ellie's head we know this because Neil
druckman shared on Instagram an image of
Bailey posted in front of Dr Anderson's
Body now before she played Abby in part
two Laura Bailey actually played one of
these nurses in part one of the game so
this is really Laura Bailey in the
character coming full circle now there
is more to this that definitely spoils
part two of the game so skip to this
time if you just want more general
knowledge about where season 2 might go
okay so if you played part two of the
game you know that Abby is actually the
daughter of Dr Jerry Anderson the doctor
that Joel executes and she never lets go
with that Grudge we catch up with Abby
early on in part two of the game Joel
saves her she realizes who Joel is and
then beats him to death with a golf club
right in front of Ellie now this happens
early on and it shot the hell out of
everyone and you actually have to play
as Abby at one point it was a hugely
controversial move but it is true to
what Neil druckman always wanted to do
with the Last of Us games to force game
players into the shoes of these morally
compromised characters so in this photo
when Laura Bailey poses over the body of
Dr Anderson truckman said Bailey said
that she captured it with Daddy
so when I look ahead to season two I
keep going back and forth on when they
plan to put Joel's death in season two
like if they were mapping part two of
the game exactly on the second season I
would say early on but if they're gonna
be taking their time with multiple
seasons of part two as has been
confirmed basing out season two with
like cutaways and flashbacks I could see
them squeezing out another full Nine
episodes out of Pedro Pascal to save his
death for the finale okay so that covers
our big spoilers section welcome back so
Neil druckman said that when they tested
out part one of the game game testers
all thought the last of us would play
out like The Telltale Game series
because this was an era of video games
where the big Trend was let the player
make the choice of Where The Story Goes
game testers are The Last of Us thought
that they would be given the option to
save Ellie or not in the hospital and
they were all surprised to find out that
they were just forced to save Ellie and
to live with that truckman had it that
tester said I can't believe you made me
kill the doctor and those nurses and
druckman would say whoa wait you didn't
have to kill the nurses too you only
have to kill the doctor with the scalpel
to be able to grab Ellie you can totally
spare the nurses if you want but many
game players let the violent let's take
over them and took out those nurses too
Dante torched the whole freaking room
touch my girl you won't get the chance
now the show takes the somewhat Kinder
path by having Joel spare the nurses
just to prove that point but it also
makes one major change here in the game
there are two nurses one of them played
by Laura Bailey as is the case here but
in this show there is a mysterious third
nurse hanging back in the shadows
shaving is one of those things that I
missed the opportunity to learn how to
do properly because that was a hormonal
teenager who was tired of having my dad
explain things to me as an adult I'm
grateful for anything that can take my
lack of Shaving skill and make up for it
just by being a great razor you know
like Harry's
Harry's blades are super sharp so I can
finally get that close double freeze
shave that I've heard so much about and
the handle is textured so I have a good
grip and I can get my angle just right
even when I'm doing that weird little
area just at the corner of my jaw the
starter set came with a five blade razor
cartridge designed by German Engineers a
weighted handle and shaving cream with
aloe to keep my face soft as well as a
travel blade cover so I can toss my
blade in my bag when I'm on the go if
you like me or somebody who spent their
whole life feeling like they just didn't
get shaving you should get Harry's just
click the link in the description box
below to buy a Harry's trial set for
just five dollars the set is worth 13
but you're only paying five dollars
again click the link in the description
box below to get your discounted trial
set from Harry's today why did they add
a third nurse to this scene I believe
this nurse is Abby scrubbed up to help
with this operation and I think that
we're gonna flash back to this moment
from Abby's point of view some viewers
thought Abby was snuck in earlier to the
hospital shootout like when Joel shoots
at those two fireflies at the nursing
station one Firefly provides cover fire
while another one rounds the corner and
flees down the hall some viewers thought
that they saw a ponytail bouncing off
that Runner but no this is a man that
ponytail is really just a strap on his
backpack still ultimately I think Abby
was in this Hospital season two will
spend more time in the town of Jackson
part two of the game starts there and so
all the episode 6 events in Jackson were
inspired by those early sections of part
two of the game that includes that
subtle moment when Ellie noticed that
girl staring at her what
what's wrong with you Drake been amazing
confirmed this character might be Dina
someone in Ellie's World in part two of
the games we don't know if the character
will be recast with a new actor in
season two now how is season 2 going to
be structured chuckman and Mason in
every interview have said that fourth
season two their process will be the
same as it was for season one to
identify one thematic through line for
the story and to find ways in every
episode to address it including shifting
away from the main character's points of
view to other world events we saw that
in season one with the 1960s talk show
the Mycologist and Jakarta the bill and
Frank episode Kathleen's community in
Kansas City David's community at the
Lakeside Resort Ellie's birth from Anna
one episode was mostly a flashback with
Ellie and Riley adapting the Left Behind
DLC all in all events from just part one
of the game accounted for roughly just
60 percent of what we saw across those
Nine episodes Mason confirmed this
shifting around a point of view in the
official HBO after Show podcast when he
was asked about the second season and we
will also take advantage of the freedom
we have in television
that wasn't there in the game
specifically the advantage of changing
perspective so we will use what we can
use in a new medium to tell that story
and another promise they made for season
two was to include more horror from the
infected because I think for some
cynical viewers they were tapping on
their TV screen saying now there are
going to be zombies in this zombie show
right it's not a zombie show but you
know this is the genre of this kind of
horror I think people expected something
similar to the gameplay in the gameplay
clickers Runners bloaters are attacking
the characters constantly you don't
really get a reprieve from them Mason
also said that they will be be exploring
more that new world detail from the show
the cordyceps underground Network that
Tess talked about in episode 2 actually
Anna actress Ellie from The Games Ashley
Johnson asked Mason and directman about
this and listen how they respond
knowingly as she asks it there's
something that and I don't know if this
will ever transfer over to the game from
the show
but in watching the episodes and and how
the fungus is a little different and how
are you step on things and it can
attract hundreds yes that I will say is
something that I think we will be
exploring further in the next season I
think this first time around we were
learning so much about how to create the
infected and how to televise them in a
way that was exciting and didn't seem
goofy or weird or artificial or and I
think we've figured out that and I think
this next season the interconnectivity
of them and the risk of stepping on the
wrong thing that stuff is going to be
brought forward more for sure druckman
has also indicated the underground
Network could be something woven in
part three of the games if that ever
happens and there has been a lot of
speculation that naughty dog is secretly
working on a part three and is waiting
to announce in that Naughty Dogs next
big game struckman interestingly is not
directing which could free up his
schedule to be working on the Last of Us
Part three I don't know from you how
many seasons do you want the last of us
to run for honestly I'm good with just
three seasons and if there's a third
part of the game we can have future
Seasons down the road but yeah I don't
need shows to run forever and ever now
comment down below with your thoughts
another reminder to subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive and support us by
grabbing something from the deep dive
collection and nerd riot.shop follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you